bienvenue pour ce nouveau journal sur tv
fil 78 dans l'actualité blinoise de ce 3
avril lors des départementales nous
avons voté pour des binômes homme femme
mais quels sont les postes occupés
maintenant par ces dernières le point
dans notre département politique
également avec ces élus qui veulent la
création d'un comité départemental de
liaison de la gauche dans les yvelines
le prg en est à l'initiative son
président départemental conseiller
régional et diane est l'invité de cette
édition et puis comme chaque vendredi le
point sur l'essentiel depuis lundi
semaine de l'industrie combat de rsf
pour un lycéen sans papiers et
préparatifs du week end de pâques
pierre bédier a donc été réélu hier
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines sans surprise il était le seul
candidat à ce fauteuil et recueille 38
voix quatre bulletins étaient blancs
dans son discours il a appelé à la
mobilisation de tous les élus dans un
esprit d'humilité de combat rappelons
qu'il n'ya maintenant plus aucune
opposition les alliés du centre et de la
droite ayant raflé tous les postes ce
conseil départemental en tout cas été
renouvelé à 60 % et cse et surtout il
est composé maintenant d'autant d'hommes
que de femmes c'est une nouveauté mais
qu'est-ce que cela va changer les
explications une ambiance rentrée des
classes pour ce nouveau conseil
départemental et pour beaucoup d'élus us
une première dans une assemblée jusqu'à
présent très masculine elles sont 21 à
siéger une parité rendue obligatoire par
la loi alors qu'on pense le nouvel élu
là le fait d'avoir joué le jeu de cette
parité me semble vraiment extra
c'est bien parce que effectivement on va
dire oui mais alors c'est parce que vous
êtes une femme que vous êtes vice
présidente
s'il n'y avait pas la parité non dans ce
cas là c'est pas le cas 1 on est bien
d'accord
donc j'espère que c'est parce qu'on
considère qu'on a quelques compétences
et quelques possibilités
on est aussi bon que les hommes 1 après
journée christine boutin est la doyenne
de l'assemblée elle a aussi tenu à
rappeler qu'elle était la conseillère
départementale au mandat le plus long de
paul ou taillon à pierre bédier
la connu le changement dans l'hémicycle
ça ne m'a jamais fait flipper dans un
sens ou dans un autre ces histoires de
parité j'avais pas voter la loi sur la
parité jeu très contente de voir qu'il
ya des femmes ce qui m'intéresse c'est
des gens compétents ce soit des hommes
des femmes voilà bon très bien non ce
qui est plus important c'est le
renouvellement puisque 60% de nouveaux
conseillers départementaux
ça ça me semble effectivement être être
important la parité elle se retrouve
également au niveau des vice présidences
et de la commission permanente alors un
bouleversement pour ces messieurs nous
avons choisi d'être dans la loi et dans
l'esprit de la loi et donc de faire
qu'il y ait un partage
tout à fait égal à l'exception de la
présidence mais j'essaierai d'avoir ma
part de féminité
moi je suis d'une génération qui a
toujours été à l'école avec les filles
j'ai toujours connu la mixité la
politique ne l'avait fait perdre cette
mixité que j'avais connu à l'école
maternelle et dans toutes les allées les
études que j'ai pu faire après donc moi
je ne fais pas de différence
hommes-femmes
la différence sera peut-être plus marqué
au moment des débats certaines femmes
politiques sont déjà bien connus pour
leur franc parler elle était le binôme
de michel laugier pendant ces
départementale sur le canton de montigny
le bretonneux la voici donc maintenant
au sein de l'hémicycle laurence trochut
à peine élue conseillère départementale
doit faire face à une fronde de son
groupe au sein du conseil municipal de
guyancourt trois élus ont décidé de se
désolidariser d'elle et de ladislas
secouera pour créer leur propre groupe
d'opposition il évoque dans un
communiqué de presse un manque de
concertation de travail d'équipé ou
encore d'engagement citoyen un revers
pour la nouvelle conseillère
départementale
c'est une dissidence qui cause beaucoup
de tristesse qui n'était effectivement
pas attendue puisqu'elle n'a pas été
annoncé nous l'avons découverte nous
mêmes en conseil municipal mardi soir
donc c'est vrai que ça génère ça génère
ce sentiment de tristesse et puis de
déception aussi parce que c'est vrai
qu'on n'y voit là quand même un peu de
l'acheter dans la mesure où
où il aurait fallu quand même que cette
équipe je dirais travaillent ensemble à
réunir ses forces
l'invité de ce vendredi 3 avril et dit
bonjour bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
régional d'île de france président du
prg dans les yvelines le parti radical
de gauche qui lance un appel pour la
création d'un comité départemental de
liaison de la gauche dans les yvelines
alors à qui s'adresse cet appel est ce
que ça concerne l'ensemble de la gauche
socialiste inclut bien évidemment
l'ensemble de la gauche sans aucune
exclusive socialistes écologistes amis
du parti de robert hue les communistes
le front de gauche dans sa globalité
l'idée vraiment de saisir la malheureuse
opportunité qui découpe des sélections
départementales pour que nous ayons une
démarche de rassemblement que nous nous
retrouvions pour poser les bases d'un
accord d'une discussion commune alors
lancé un appel vouloir le rassemblement
c'est les marges positives mais après
derrière il faut des actes est ce que
vous sentez que l'ensemble des
formations et je reviens encore sur les
socialistes sont d'accord pour se
rassembler parce que on sent bien europe
écologie les verts front de gauche que
ce soit au niveau national que ce soit
au niveau local avec le parti socialiste
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des postures
clivante au sein de la gauche entre les
pro et les anti gouvernement en
maintenant la démarche du rassemblement
les basée sur le fait que ensemble à
l'issue d'une discussion on a listé les
points d'accord et c'est sur ces points
d'accord que nous allons ensemble à
l'affrontement face à la droite et le
centre qui a su lui se rassembler au
premier tour de ces élections
départementales
le parti socialiste est plutôt dans un
esprit favorable entamé un certain
nombre de rencontres
nous avons déjà eu des retours également
sur un accord de principe d'écologistes
un accord de principe des amis du parti
de robert hue donc je ne désespère pas
aujourd'hui que nous puissions avancer
mais la démarche elle prendra le temps
nécessaire pour qu'elle soit un succès
faut rien précipiter
rien forcer surtout obliger personne à
se renier sur ce qui constitue les
fondamentaux de son parti faut rien
précipiter mais des élections qui vont
approcher là on en sort mais il y en a
d'autres encore ce sont les élections
régionales et vous les connaissez
forcément bien puisque vous êtes conseil
régional et vous êtes dans le groupe de
la majorité de jean paul huchon
socialiste président socialiste c'est ça
c'est l'inquiétude c'est de se dire
voilà on va dans le mur on va perdre
aussi les régions
s'il faut pas se précipiter il faut
aller vite quand même puisque les
échéances elles sont là que ce soit les
régionales et puis à très très long
terme
les élections municipales de 2001 mais
la réalité elle est que nous devrions
tirer cette notion évidemment il ya des
leçons à tirer de ce scrutin car on doit
pas refaire les mêmes
or ce n'est pas la division qui a fait
perdre ans est le deuxième tour il est
de toute façon une amplification du
premier la diversité s'est exprimée
parce que les conditions du
rassemblement n'avait pas été créée mais
on nous sommes tous responsables de cela
parce que nous ne sommes pas retrouvés
un moment donné donc les régionales
doivent être le symbole de cette
capacité à se retrouver
et si c'est pas sur des listes de
premier tour c'est en tout cas la
nécessité à donner du sens à l'unité
pour qu'au deuxième tour la dynamique
soit de notre côté et qu'on ne soit pas
simplement dans un phénomène qui
transforme l'essai si par malheur on
n'était pas en tête au premier tour pour
fermer la parenthèse sur ces régionales
justement votre démarche c'est quoi
c'est l'alliance avec le parti
socialiste pour le prg
elle porte sur un dicale de gauche et
dans une démarche d'unité donc nous
rencontrons régulièrement le président
de la région ile de france
nous rencontrons régulièrement le
président du groupe socialiste à la
région ile de france ainsi que les élus
socialistes du département pour poser
les bases d'un accord et d'un
rassemblement parti radical de gauche a
déjà mis en place une démarche de
consultation à travers des groupes de
travail à travers un site participatif
il sera très prochainement lancer notre
idée créer les conditions du
rassemblement
y'a pas de problème à ce que la gauche
gouverner ensemble si les diversités et
sensibilités sont respectés à la région
ile-de-france on l'a toujours fait j'ai
pas trop inquiet de ce sera avec jean
paul huchon
parce que ça doit être vrai social pas
mais fin mai le parti socialiste devra
devra se prononcer dans le cadre d'une
primaire ne suis pas adhérent au parti
socialiste ça vous faire un peu de
langue de bois mais je dirais ça ne
concerne pas de rennes laval ils sont
même assez long cela ne concerne pas
d'un point de vue technique ce moment
aujourd'hui c'est vrai je participe à un
exécutif qui est celui de jean paul
huchon
je suis élu à ses côtés depuis 2004
n'a pas maltraiter le parti radical de
gauche même si parfois on n'a pas
toujours obtenu satisfaction sur les
demandes qui étaient les nôtres mais je
crois que le jeu interne des militants
doit être respectée
maintenant l'objectif du parti radical
de gauche est de favoriser le
rassemblement autour du candidat du
parti socialiste et de permettre que
nous gagnons
cette région parce que moi je préfère
être dans l'espoir de si vous voulez
dans l'espoir de conserver cette région
que dans la crainte de la perdre et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui
valérie pécresse n'est pas la bonne
candidate elle est trop clivante à
droite et que la gauche si elle sera
sans forte de son bilan elle peut
conserver cette région vous pensé pour
revenir sur cette question du
rassemblement que les militants vont
suivre justement et au delà des
militants est ce que les électeurs aussi
vont suivre parce que sur le second tour
même si personne n'est propriétaire de
ses voix n'y a pas eu d'appel d'europe
écologie et du front de gauche a voté a
clairement pour soutenir les socialistes
les électeurs sont pas déplacés au fond
chacun a fait un petit peu sont son
choix même si vous vous regroupez vous
n'allez pas perdre les électeurs en
cours de route ils vont pas dire bon bah
maintenant ils se mettent d'accord juste
parce qu'ils ont peur de perdre des
postes faut pas espérer que le travail
qui a été fait au premier tour soit fait
sur le deuxième
nos militants doivent réapprendre à se
connaître sur le terrain dans le
département des yvelines et les éleveurs
à faire confiance dit kadhafi d'avoir
des copains celui d'un projet ailleurs
les lecteurs qui se positionne à gauche
puissent se retrouver quand il ya
cacophonie qu'anti la dispersion et
quand les chefs des partis soient
nationaux ou départementaux ne montre
pas l'exemple sur la voie de la
dynamique du rassemblement
la droite a été beaucoup plus maligne
même si l'enjeu que le buzz que le
département bascule à gauche était quand
même inexistant s'étaient sentis l'assun
voile a créé les conditions pour rendre
comme si c'était inattendu la maîtrise
département mais le grand chelem ça fait
des mois que le prg s'en inquiète et
rappeler à leurs responsabilités
l'ensemble des partis de gauche ce
premier rappel n'avait pas été entendu
celui ci aujourd'hui par nécessité devra
l'être sur le programme sur le fond
quels sont les points d'accord
aujourd'hui qui peuvent permettre de
faire émerger une entente un
rassemblement au niveau régional au
niveau local déjà à l'autre à toutes les
problématiques liées à l'environnement
et la transition énergétique sur
laquelle aujourd'hui tous les partis de
gauche ou un véritable discours
ambitieux volontariste qui n'est pas le
cas de la droite sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat et de la relance de la
croissance alors certes là il ya des
nuances mais aujourd'hui la nécessité de
lutter durablement contre le chômage
avait encore plus forte et je crois que
si la gauche a été sanctionnée c'est
parce que nous n'avons pas réussi à
tenir cette promesse républicaine
d'accès à l'emploi pour toutes et tous
donc il faudra que nous rappelions ici
notre engagement et annoncé des
propositions fortes
nous devons encore améliorer également
ce travail en commun et les propositions
elles vont naître de ces groupes de
travail de ces échanges
car je dirais que le logiciel de gauche
il n'est pas périmé
les parents panne il est là il est
existant il est porté différemment donc
il est moins entendu et il est moins
porté collectivement parce qu'il est
porté dans une cacophonie qui apparaît
comme de la division même s'il n'ya rien
de mal à ce que la gauche s'exprime dans
sa diversité seulement un moment donné
une échéance électorale
elle se présente à front uni et elle se
présente pour être abordés le sens de la
victoire ça on parlait du local b pour
un accord sur le local au niveau
national est ce que ça passe par un
remaniement aussi est-ce qu'il faut une
ouverture du gouvernement aux différents
élus il apparaît que si un remaniement
se fait ce sera avant l'été enfin
courant juin les écologie se rassemblent
prochainement pour savoir quelles sont
leurs logiques le parti socialiste
entamer des négociations
le parti radical de gauche vous savez
dispose de trois ministres au
gouvernement
sport coopération francophonie et
ministre ministère des territoires
si un remaniement doit se faire et
doivent faire dans une logique de
renforcement et surtout d'ouverture à
d'autres membres de la majorité car
c'est vrai que l'électeur de gauche ou
militants comprend pas un moment donné
que toutes les sensibilités ne se
retrouve pas dans ce gouvernement et ça
veut peut-être dire aussi et le parti
radical de gauche le réclame qui est une
inflexion sur certain nombre de choix et
je pense notamment à la question des
dotations globales de fonctionnement aux
collectivités territoriales là il faut
lâcher du lest car l'investissement
public portés par les collectivités
locales ne peut pas être freiné et c'est
clairement un curseur à gauche que
l'investissement public
donc il faut aller vite mais il ya
beaucoup de travail pourquoi ai je crois
qu'on inspire pas au repos et que même
si on le souhaitait l'actualité ne nous
y invite pas merci éditrice tient du prg
dans lé les yvelines également
conseiller régional d'île de france
merci à eux aussi se divisent mais à
droite pas moins de trois listes pour la
prochaine élection municipale de
voisins-le-bretonneux une seule à gauche
le point sur ce scrutin qui se déroulera
le 12 avril le dimanche 12 avril les
électeurs vis chinois sont appelés aux
urnes pour le premier tour de l'élection
municipale partielle
ils doivent élire 33 conseillers
municipaux après l'annulation de
l'élection le 25 février dernier les
électeurs auront le choix entre quatre
listes tout d'abord la liste voisins ma
ville emmenés par thierry gastaud ancien
directeur de cabinet d'alexis biette
l'ancien maire de voisins-le-bretonneux
alexis piette qui figure assez loin sur
cette liste à la 19ème position
il ne figure pas non plus parmi les
candidats désignés
pour siéger au conseil communautaire de
la casse qui s'est d'ores et déjà un
revers pour lui puisque jusqu'à la
décision du conseil d'état il siégeait à
la communauté d'agglomération deuxième
liste celle de tous rassemblés pour
voisin porté par olivier afonso 39 ans
président de l'association syndicale
champ fleuri dans sa liste figure
notamment en troisième position jean
louis qu'ils ont il avait été tête de
liste en mars 2014 pour les municipales
olivier affonso souhaite défendre des
valeurs d'intérêt général de moralité et
de famille troisième liste vivre voisin
menée par alexandra rosetti la maire
sortante
parmi ses colistiers on retrouve ceux
élus en mars dernier gardons le cap
son slogan de campagne le tissu
économique le vivre ensemble ou encore
l'aménagement reste ses priorités enfin
dernière liste celle de jean h élus de
gauche avec pour voisin avec vous jean h
et conseiller municipal à voisin de
bretagne depuis 95 dans sa lettre
d'intention l'élu d'opposition veut
défendre les valeurs de gauche et
d'humanisme que sont pour lui la justice
sociale la solidarité ou le cadre de vie
les élections municipales de
voisins-le-bretonneux avait été annulée
par le conseil d'état le 25 février
après le recours déposé par l'ancien
maire alexis blettes en cause les cards
15 voix seulement entre lui et alexandre
arrosée qui est la diffusion de tracts
le samedi du second tour ce qui était
interdit premier tour donc de cette
municipale partielle le dimanche 12
avril et radio sensations vous propose
un débat entre ces différentes des ses
différents candidats différentes listes
débat préparée et présentée par un
nicolas kirilow vide ce sera dimanche à
18h sur le 98 points 4 mais aussi sur
notre antenne en simultané aurait
diffusion lundi sur tv fils à 18h
également parmi les thématiques
circulation logement ou encore éducation
nous revenons à présent sur l'essentiel
de la semaine comme chaque vendredi
visite d'entreprise ateliers
pédagogiques conférences expositions
c'était le programme de la semaine de
l'industrie qui se déroulait dans le
département retour sur ce forum ouvert
aux jeunes qui s'est tenue mardi à la
cci
et aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que nous
entend distribuer du genre on a besoin
d'être de l'engager franc et direct il
parle de son métier avec passion patrick
mitchell a créé son entreprise de moyens
d'assemblage pour l'industrie
aéronautique en 97 à houdan il compte
aujourd'hui 23 salariés et vient
d'ouvrir une filiale au texas pour
attaquer dit-il le marché américain une
filiale dirigée par un salarié recruté
il ya quatre ans à la sortie de son bac
pro
une belge à succès story à la française
qu'il est venu partager avec ses élèves
souvent peu au fait des réalités du
monde de l'industrie ions ils ne
connaissent pas assez c'est évident j'ai
tendance à dire que ce petit lait pour
les profs qui veut le renvoyer un stage
en entreprise
je me suis dit ça très gentiment mais en
tout cas c'est pas les profs qui peuvent
leur expliquer je pense qu'il faut il
faudrait que même à leur niveau ils
puissent faire des stages en entreprise
plus souvent raconté son expérience et
faire aimer un secteur qui offre des
emplois mais qui a du mal à trouver des
candidats
tout l'objectif de ces rencontres
organisées à la cci via le réseau
coaxial tous les filières réclus tous
plus ou moins celle ont effectivement
les profils les spécificités il a
beaucoup dans la mécanique qui est très
recherché l'aéronautique c'est les
filières dans lesquelles et il y en a
énormément de recherches aujourd'hui et
qui défilèrent combo une vraie
découverte en tout cas pour les 106
élèves reçus ce mardi ils sont issus de
formations très différente second
professionnels terminale section
technologique ou même classe prépa moi
je connaissais vraiment pas à grand
chose sur ce secteur là et donc ça a été
extrêmement intéressant de pouvoir
elle se rend compte que c'est pas du
tout ce à quoi on pouvait penser et on
s'était vraiment très intéressant d'en
savoir plus donc on n'est pas grand
chose sur l'entreprise sur les
industries donc ça nous a permis de des
food et tout ce qu'on savait pas et
c'était vraiment très enrichissante
ça nous permet de
de nouvelles perspectives pour l'avenir
pour l'industrie c'est l'automobile
automobile qui commentent qui qui
licencient mais l'industrie c'est plein
d'autres métiers et l'industrie du lait
c'est l'industrie du livre c'est
l'industrie la cosmétique donc il ya
vraiment sur notre territoire une
richesse d'entreprises et de domaine
qu'il faut faire découvrir à nos jeunes
citent aussi en faisant un pétiller des
yeux et en plantant des graines que
l'orientation se fait que la réflexion
sur ce qu'on va devenir peut se faire
mission accomplie 20 chefs d'entreprises
ont répondu présent ce jour là la
semaine de l'industrie se poursuit
jusqu'au 5 avril
ce mercredi un forum de l'alternance est
organisée à l'université versailles
saint quentin 150 offres concrètes
seront proposés l'industrie dans les
yvelines pourquoi pas à ces plans
anticrises société maintenant avec le
cas de cet étudiant guinéen arrivé en
france en mai 2014 et qui se retrouve
aujourd'hui à la rue alors qu'il est
toujours scolarisé au lycée jean perrin
à saint cyr l'école aujourd'hui ce sont
des militants du réseau d'éducation sans
frontières rsf et qui l'héberge qui lui
cherche une solution durable les
explications c'est l'histoire de mamadou
oury 18 ans lycéen est déjà sans
domicile fixe cet adolescent guinéen
arrivé en france il ya un an a été pris
en charge par l'aide sociale à l'enfance
qui lui a fourni un logement majeures
depuis le 25 mars est toujours scolarisé
il se retrouve aujourd'hui expulsé de sa
chambre d'hôtel sans aucun suivi social
j'étais riche de laisser rentrer avec
moi je n'ai pas à les trouver la clé de
la chance j'ai demandé la patronne en
fait la patronne m'a dit que que le
concessionnaire est rappelé que deux
ak partie de trezeguet vont occuper
l'hôtel de la région de se retrouver là
considéré comme apte à subvenir à ses
besoins mamadou oury s'est alors vu
retirer son logement
pourtant son profil lui autorisé à
signer un contrat jeune majeur qui lui
permettrait de poursuivre ses études
parce que vous recherchez études il te
faut des personnes qui doit être la
porte en psycho logiquement et surtout
vos prochains proposé aux deux études il
faut des tuteurs et tout donne il faut
il te faut une adresse donc qu'on a
demandé à la responsable des
prolongations bien si c'est pas juste
avoir le contrat jeune majeur mais juste
avoir une prolongation jusqu'au vers la
fin de l'année scolaire pour pouvoir
parce que une faut du temps pour vous
préparer contenu les obstacles qui vont
arriver donc ce que l'on demande bien
sûr c'est que le conseil général
réétudie sa position de façon à ce que
ils le
le prennent en charge jusqu'à la fin de
l'année jusqu'à jusqu'à début de l'année
scolaire prochaine puisque en fin de
compte mamadou oury veut continuer ses
études en et en ayant en étant en
alternance ce qui lui permettra d'avoir
à un revenu minimum mais au moins un
revenu pour pouvoir se prendre en charge
lui-même pour pouvoir bénéficier du
contrat jeune majeur mamadou est à la
recherche d'un patron pour continuer sa
formation en alternance dès la rentrée
2015 pour le moment l'adolescent est
hébergé par des militants du réseau
d'éducation sans frontières également
soutenue par ses professeurs et son club
de foot
le conseil général joint par téléphone
n'a pas donné suite à notre demande
d'entretien
un nouveau prix pour les cuisiniers des
yvelines eddie benghanem chef pâtissier
du trianon à versailles et son équipe
viennent de remporter le prix du
meilleur dessert un dessert aux saveurs
exotiques et aux textures surprenante ce
mélange gastronomique a permis au chef
pâtissier du trianon palace
eddie benghanem et à son équipe de
remporter le prix le b un concours qui
récompense les meilleurs plats en
ile-de-france la composition du dessert
proposé par le chef yvelinois est pour
le moins surprenante est en fait un
désert signature donc la forme toujours
identique forme d'oeuf à l'intérieur une
mousse qui peut être au chocolat noir
blanc ou au lait là c'était une mousse à
notre coco un sorbet qui vous prêtent
aux fruits rouges ou un nouveau parfum
là on est atterré ce temps le thème de
l'ananas compter nos deux d'ananas et de
coco comme une piña colada donc sans
bananes ananas rôti 1a frères une mousse
extra légère à la noix de coco et puis
un croustillant ultra répressif est
extrêmement gourmand la lettre qu on est
sûr de la fraîcheur
on est sur un visuel assez élégant bien
sûr et on est sur un tacle ou de frais
régressif et extrêmement gourmand
cette distinction est une belle
reconnaissance pour ce pâtissier de 42
ans passé par le ritz l'hôtel de crillon
encore le georges 5 et qui a posé ses
ustensiles de cuisine et ses casseroles
au trianon palace en 2008 ils étaient
super choix de quoi c'était vraiment
jeter dans les bras c'est ce qui me
resteront très très très content content
d'avoir remporté ce concours
content de la reconnaissance de
des gens qui ont noté ce dessert là et
content d'eux pour mes amis qui me
connaissent bien où des gens de la
profession qui me connaissent bien qui
était aussi enthousiaste que moi quoi ce
dessert soit remis à la carte dans une
quinzaine de jours pour la période
estivale au trianon palace de versailles
on en salive d'avancé
on reste dans les sucreries pâques c'est
ce week end et les professionnels du
chocolat sont très plus que quelques
jours à tenir avant de pouvoir céder à
la gourmandise au laboratoire de bosses
on apporte les dernières touches aux
commandes et pour les fêtes de pâques
les classiques ont toujours la cote à
particules c'est quand même la
traditionnelle c'est d'abord les deux
les cloches les poissons après les
petits montages mais c'est surtout leur
chocolat noir chocolat au lait praliné
pour les fêtes de pâques franck de
bosses et ses employés produit jusqu'à
une bonne 400 de chocolat pour
satisfaire les gourmands et 18 18 à 20%
2 du chiffre d'affaires en chocolat
après ça dépend des périodes explique
plaque ça tombe mal cet atome pendant
les vacances
bah tout de suite entre un document bien
que si c'est comme cette année
les classes vont être bientôt finalisé
de quoi pouvoir nous livrer à temps le
journal revient mardi au même horaire
excellent o'cain de pâques